problema
43.000 a determinó el área de esta
figura la de acá dividiendo en
rectángulos como se muestra e hizo
123 rectángulos me imagino que calculó
el área de cada uno como elegimos en
algún problema anterior y luego lo sumo
la pregunta es en cuál de las siguientes
figuras me la puede usar la misma
técnica bueno déjame bajar un poco para
ver las la yo creo que no si intentamos
trazar un rectángulo acá luego estos
trapecios no vamos a poder dividirlos en
rectángulos o si le hacemos así no me
parece que están definitivamente
definitivamente si podemos dividir en
triángulos como algo así verdad más o
menos pero en rectángulos pues me parece
que no se puede vamos a ponerle por el
momento que no está tampoco se va a
poner poder dividir el rectángulos por
estas esquinas esto nunca lo voy a poder
cubrir con un rectángulo por más que me
acerque
entonces esta tampoco sería la cesta un
poco más cerca porque ya tiene algunos
ángulos rectos pero si aquí pongo este y
aquí pongo este pues este triángulo de
acá es un triángulo rectángulo pero no
se puede dividir con con rectángulos
entonces éste tampoco y este de acá si
está parece ser que si simplemente
prolongamos este lado y nos quedan 12
rectángulos la respuesta sería de muy
bien vamos al problema
44 el problema 44 dice que
simplifiquemos esta expresión de acá muy
bien déjame copiarla es x al cuadrado
menos 3 x más 1 y luego hay que restarle
esta de acá vamos a distribuir este
signo menos es menos x al cuadrado menos
2 x menos 7 menos 7 sale menos por x
cuadrado es menos x cuadrada menos por 2
x es menos x y menos por 7 es menos 7 y
ahora vamos a simplificar x al cuadrado
menos x al cuadrado se van menos 3 x 2 x
es menos 5 x 1 menos 7 es menos 6
entonces la respuesta sería 5 x menos 6
x aquí está así es la opción c menos 5 x
6 muy bien vamos al problema 45 pregunta
cuáles son las coordenadas de la
intersección con el eje x de la línea 3
x 4 igual a 12 bueno pues la
intersección con el eje x es la
siguiente imagínate que tenemos aquí los
ejes
y que tenemos una recta más o menos así
voy a pintar una recta rosa algo de este
estilo entonces lo que buscamos la
intersección con el eje x es justo este
punto de acá este punto de acá y ese
punto tiene coordenada igual a cero sí
porque no está para arriba ni para abajo
este punto tiene una cierta coordenada
digamos x0 la coordenada en cero y lo
que buscamos es esta x de acá vale
entonces si tenemos esta ecuación 3 x +
4 ya igual a 12 lo que buscamos es ver
cuánto vale x cuando lleva al es cero
vamos a hacerlo tenemos 3 x + 4 james
igual a 12 pero hoy es igual a 0 esto es
igual a 0 entonces 3x es igual a 12 y
dividiendo entre 3 de ambos lados para
cancelar este 3 aquí se cancela y aquí
nos queda que x es igual a 12 entre 3 o
sea que x es igual a 4 x es igual a 4
ok x es igual a 4 y es igual a 0
entonces el punto que nos interesa es el
40 que corresponde a la opción de y de
hecho podríamos eliminar la opción hay
la opción se inmediatamente porque éstas
no son intersecciones con el eje x sino
con el eje porque sus coordenadas sus
coordenadas en x son iguales a 0 vale
bueno vamos al problema 46 ahora en el
problema 46 nos preguntan cuál de los
siguientes enunciados describe a las
rectas paralelas las rectas paralelas
son parejas de rectas que tienen la
misma dirección por ejemplo estas dos
las dos van para allá las dos van para
allá pero no pueden estar encima das la
una en la otra es decir no pueden ser la
misma recta vale bueno vamos a ver
misma intersección con el eje y pero
diferentes pendientes
no queremos que tenga diferentes
pendientes dije que deben de tener la
misma dirección o sea la misma pendiente
entonces ésta no sería misma pendiente
pero diferente intersección con el eje y
si esto es justo lo que necesitamos
verdad que vayan en la misma dirección
pero que crucen en algún eje diferente
por ejemplo si una cosa aquí y otra acá
entonces si son rectas diferentes y como
tienen la misma pendiente tienen la
misma dirección se pendientes opuestas
pero misma intersección con el eje x no
queremos que tengan la misma pendiente
intersecciones con el eje de keops eje
en el eje x opuestas esto está raro pero
con el eje iguales pues no esto no no es
lo que queremos lo que queremos es la
opción b